Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Connors. This is module seven of the stop fighting cancer series that
Goes along with my book that is trying to help people
With the next steps on how to deal with their cancer and we can't ignore this step
This perhaps is in my mind the most important step in your life
You know, we're trying to deal with cancer and we're trying to heal and we want to get better and we want to live longer and
Somehow we think we deserve to be out of earth the day. D
hundred years or whatever
Hopefully those that are listening to this are thinking no, that's not really me my real purpose
So this is just to do my part and to stay alive
I don't think I'm supposed to just succumb to a disease and just let it take its course
I have a work to do here too. That's my philosophy
I believe that God is sovereign in all things and
This cancer can't kill me because I have already died to Christ and
Death is a victory for me. It doesn't have the stigma that it has if I don't have a hope for the other side
And I have that hope and I want you to have that hope because ultimately that's what it's about
I've said for years that my purpose as a doctor isn't to keep people alive at other 5 or 10 years so they can still just die and go to hell
What good is that?
Ultimately, we are eternal beings living on this earth and
We will spend eternity somewhere and my desire is that
You spend eternity with me in heaven. That is my ultimate desire
I'm not here to be a preacher, but I am here to be a believer and to share my truth
That that I know that God has taught me with you and
I know that if we ignore our heart what are we're dealing with disease and we ignore the
Depth of our disease
From an eternal perspective we're missing the whole boat of this
It's not about just staying alive for a few more years and enjoying our grandkids or
Or our animals or our life or our things or our stuff
It's about giving him glory in all things even in our last days and we don't want to finish in a poor way
So we don't want to ignore our heart. We don't want to ignore the deeper things than non-physical things because those are
The most important things. I trust in God's sovereignty
That he is working a work in me even with my cancer
If you don't think that I'm going through the same thing as you are going through if you're dealing with some
Type of cancer right now. Go back to our website and watch
My videos on my personal journey
I too went through some very dark times and I do believe that God
Allows us to go through some very scary hard times in life
That's how he disciplines us. That's how he molds us and that's how he shapes us because that's the ultimately his purpose for us
Is to be molded and shaped more and more to the image of his son to obedient children
That's what his desire for us is in this and I think in my cancer
God has a desire to work that work in me and I need to let him work that work in me
So trust in God's sovereignty seek him first. That's the ultimate thing
I tell my patients over and over again do not make an idol out of treating your cancer
That is very sinful
Yes, do your part, you know eat right take your supplements do your therapies do what you need to do
But certainly do be very careful of making an idol out of staying alive
That you're working so hard. I got to stay alive. I got to do these things that you spend more time
Doing the things that you think you need to do to stay alive that you are spending time seeking him
He said seek me first and the kingdom will be added to you
That's the only way the kingdom is going to be added to you and this kingdom isn't here on earth
The kingdom is in eternity
It isn't staying alive. It isn't getting better. It isn't you know healing
our cancer
It is about
Be ready to meet him
Well, that's where our time needs to be spent. Yes, we need to do the other things to live our life to to be obedient servants of his
But we need to spend our time seeking him
And then lastly
We cannot fear
Death we cannot fear this cancer. We cannot fear what it could do to us
Yeah, nobody's too crazy about the act of dying that time not looking forward to
But be dead. I'm not
Fearful of I know where I'm going and it's only because I seek him first every day
Well, I try to I fail miserably just like everybody else does but then I get out of my face and repent what I do
Because he is the only thing that I'm living for and I need to be living for and often I fail and I'm living for stuff and living for things and living for life and living for pleasure
But my fear needs to be of him and that's the beginning of knowledge. That's what wisdom will be added to me
That's what I will know that I'll know
what my real purpose is and
That's my desire for you
You want to go deeper of this subject? I'll know my book cancer kid kill you when you're already dead
I wrote this before my cancer actually and
And
This really helped me walk through it as I remember the words that God gave me and writing this book
About how our relationship with him has to be first has to be deep and it doesn't come through a religion
And it doesn't come through a ritual and it doesn't come through an act that I did at one point in time
It comes through a daily
Dependence upon him where I am surrendered to him
A daily moment to moment basis that I know that he's working in me and I know that I can trust him
And I know that he loves me and I know that he just wants in my difficult times
When I'm sad and I'm down because I'm human that he just
Cauls me and beckons me to crawl up on his lap and he just wants to hold me like a daddy
Wants to hold his child and he wants to stroke my hair and say it's okay
I'm here. I'm with you in this. I'll walk with you through this
That's what gives me comfort. That's what gives me peace that I want that peace
To be with you also so that you truly can as Paul said just experience that fruit of that holy spirit inside of you
That is peace and patience and kindness and goodness and self-control
That you that you are just
Conquering all the other craziness that's going on in your world whether it be your body falling apart
Your family falling apart your finances falling apart. It's just those things don't matter anymore when you're
Snuggled in your father's lap that he's going to take care of you
That's my prayer for you. I
Will be praying for you know that you want to send us your picture in an email. It'll go up on a prayer board
That is not a little thing
We need to hold each other through this walk as well
Stick with it seek him always seek him first. That's the most important thing never stop seeking never stop knocking
He will be there for you. He's always been there for you
Pray that you keep praying for us. We'll keep praying for you keep coming back to the site for more information
We're going to be adding more and more to it. We want it to be a valuable tool for you walking through life
Thank you